super-powered farts and an island of
mutated beasts don't make for an easy
trip down memory lane not even a
vanishing spell can wipe these box
office flops from history
the late british actor john hurt played
a number of iconic parts in his long
career with key roles in classic fantasy
and sci-fi franchises like doctor who
alien hellboy and of course the harry
potter films where he played garrick
ollivander but there's at least one film
he starred in back in the 90s that
failed to take hold and become the next
big sci-fi film instead becoming a flop
that was the 1993 movie monolith the
film focuses on a pair of police
officers who are investigating the
passing of a young boy when they stumble
across a possible alien invader with the
ability to shapeshift hurt portrays the
government agent who wants them to leave
the case alone though it does have some
genuinely intriguing ideas it all comes
across so generic and ham-fisted that it
becomes a whole lot of nothing bad
direction bland characters a confusing
script we've seen it all before in bad b
movies that were better than this hurt
is certainly capable of playing a
chilling even terrifying villain but
he's woefully miscast in monolith and
would probably have wanted us to forget
he was ever in it
helena bonham carter would join the
harry potter series in the order of the
phoenix and return for its three sequels
as the villainous death eater bellatrix
lestrange it was a part that seems like
it was tailor-made for the frenetic
actress one time partner of tim burton
she has also starred in more than a half
dozen of his films including planet of
the apes alice in wonderland and dark
shadows across her career she's ventured
into just about every genre and dozens
of acclaimed movies but if she could
wipe one of them from existence it has
to be the strange dental comedy
novocaine the film is about a dentist
who gets framed for a murder after an
encounter with an alluring patient
played by carter who seduces him and
turns his life upside down a tonal
mishmash the movie dances between black
comedy and outright parody making one
increasingly numb to its ambitious
premise
whether it's supposed to be a genuinely
suspenseful thriller or a comic farce
you're never quite sure but when it's
all over you just want to rinse and spit
you see that's the nature of attraction
you find yourself doing things and you
have no idea why
before harry potter alan rickman already
had several well-known roles under his
belt including the sheriff of nottingham
in robin hood prince of thieves and the
villainous hans gruber in the action
classic die hard but he'd reach a new
stratosphere in the harry potter series
portraying the dark enigmatic professor
snape a wizard who seemed to blur the
line between good and evil already a
hollywood fixture the role further
cemented rickman as one of hollywood's
finest stars but rickman wasn't without
his duds and few can measure up to the
disappointment of mesmer a bizarre
biopic about franz anton mesmer mesmer
was a doctor who peddled his theories in
hypnosis and mystical energies in the
18th century the result is a film that's
about what you'd expect from a period
drama based on a forgotten figure in
pseudoscience history even if rickman is
his usual charismatic self in the title
role still the actor alone often can't
save a film though he tried he's very
kind of here
before rafe fines played a heroic
old-fashioned super spy in the king's
man the actor who starred in harry
potter as lord voldemort led a flop
called the avengers it's a movie that
finds and pretty much everyone else
involved would be thrilled to forget as
it's one of the most notorious film
failures of the 90s not only was it a
box office dud but it also came into
theaters with high expectations and was
absolutely terrible wasting a
star-studded cast and all its potential
fines played the secret agent john steed
in this big budget adaptation of the hit
british television series of the same
name but despite having all the
ingredients to be the next big action
franchise the avengers was a total
disaster and a clumsy charmless film
that didn't exactly electrify the box
office like its mcu namesake
finds himself slammed the movie telling
the guardian you don't go to work
thinking you're going to make a bad film
i went to work thinking great let's
reinvent the avengers which i loved as a
kid it's only now that we look back and
groan
actor tom felton came to fame thanks to
his casting in harry potter though he'd
had a few roles before joining the jk
rowling epic after leaving hogwarts
felton struggled to achieve the same
success as the franchise's trio of young
stars one film he took on in the wake of
harry potter that he almost certainly
regrets is the horror movie night wolf a
film that takes itself way more
seriously than it should nightwolf
centers on a group of teens in a cliched
situation stuck inside a house during a
dark and stormy night one by one they
get picked off by a mysterious creature
a werewolf of course this comes as a
complete shock to audiences who didn't
look at the title of the movie or pick
up the very obvious clues that the
filmmakers probably thought were ever so
clever felton plays the stock stoner
character gary one of the beast's first
victims so if you are checking this one
out because you love draco malfoy don't
expect to see much of him he might be
glad he didn't have to stick around for
the film's entire shoot but he probably
wishes he hadn't been there at all at
least he was smart enough to not return
for the director's next movie strippers
versus werewolves i bet you loved that
didn't you potter
joining hogwarts for harry potter and
the goblet of fire actor brendan gleeson
played mad i moody who is at first the
disguise of barty crouch jr in
subsequent films gleason returns as the
real mad eye and helps potter defeat the
dark lord voldemort a renowned irish
character actor gleason's career goes
all the way back to the late 80s and
he's gone on to feature in classics like
into the west braveheart and 28 days
later his career also has its flops
though and one actioner may be the film
the actor would love us all to skip
though it boasted a decent cast
turbulence is decidedly not a 90s
classic no matter what the filmmaker's
lofty ambitions may have been in the
film gleeson stars as stubs a bank
robber being transported by plane
alongside another diabolical criminal
named weaver who manages to break free
of his us marshall escort and take over
the flight it may have been a compelling
starting premise but with flat
performances and unimpressive stunts
turbulence crashed and burned the film's
stark similarities to conair released
the same year definitely didn't help
matters either gleason spared himself
the indignity of appearing in the two
direct-to-video sequels which were
somehow even worse
[Music]
a member of the order of the phoenix
remus lupin started out as a mysterious
figure in his first appearance with many
believing that it was he in werewolf
form who had been terrorizing hogwarts
but after the culprit was revealed to be
peter pettigrew lupin became one of the
greatest heroes of the second wizarding
war he was played by actor david fulis
who outside of harry potter has had
plenty of hit films but the disaster the
island of dr moreau was most certainly
not among them a historically bad film
it was led by marlon brando as the
eponymous doctor and boasted a
star-studded cast but it's fullest who
sparks the film's story as his character
crash-lands on the island and discovers
the experiments of the deminted moreau
who is creating bizarre mutated
half-human creatures thankfully the
film's failure doesn't rest on fueless's
shoulders that's down to brando's
laziness the film's haphazard
construction and a muddled and
meandering story but perhaps most
importantly it's just plain boring if
fuelists could back out of this one
retroactively we have no doubt he would
this is the most
outrageous spectacle i have ever
witnessed look at yourself
actress imelda staunton went from
little-known character actor to most
hated woman in households everywhere
when she gave her first performance as
the prudish professor dolores umbridge
but just four years before she came to
fame in the wizarding world staunton
made a little film she now probably
wishes she could make disappear the
virgin of liverpool you'd be forgiven
for thinking this one was a groan-worthy
adult comedy given its title and place
on this list but it's actually about a
statue of the virgin mary the film
centers on a young girl who discovers
the statue when it is being discarded by
a priest during renovations of his
church while her family is annoyed by
the statues she brings home it gets
attention from the community for
apparently performing an active miracle
in a chip shop aspiring to be a sappy
sentimental family movie it ends up a
groaner of a story that looks incredibly
cheap so it comes as no surprise to
learn that the filmmakers made the movie
just a few weeks after finding a random
script on the internet thankfully it
wasn't bad enough to prevent staunton
from being cast as one of harry potter's
most delightfully loathsome characters
deep down
you deserve to be punished
don't you mr potter
even more renowned than dame maggie
smith sir richard harris led the first
two harry potter pictures as the wise
gentle wizard dumbledore before the
star's unfortunate passing but decades
before he stepped onto hogwarts grounds
harris appeared in some of hollywood's
finest films from classics like the guns
of navarone and mutiny on the bounty to
modern greats like unforgiven and
patriot games but of course like
everyone else on this list he's got at
least one that he would take back if he
could in harris's case it's the
adventure movie tarzan the eighth man
a modern reinterpretation of the classic
novel by edgar rice burroughs the film
is not the rousing tree swinging
adventure fans might have wanted or even
expected that's because oddly enough
tarzan himself isn't even the star of
the movie with the story instead
focusing on his female companion jane
and harris playing her father here with
bo derek cast in the role of jane the
producers turned the film into little
more than softcore titillation it's
packed with enough uncomfortable adult
situations to make even john waters
blush derrick was impressed with
harris's professionalism and performance
despite the horrid script she even told
entertainment weekly the picture was
doomed but richard gave it his all
anyway
just 11 years old when he was cast as
ron weasley and harry potter and the
sorcerer's stone rupert grint hasn't
achieved the same level of box office
stardom as his co-star emma watson nor
has he appeared in highly acclaimed
arthouse films like daniel radcliffe
he's preferred instead to stick to roles
in prestige television projects such as
the abc murders with john malkovich and
snatch a series adapted from the guy
ritchie film but back when he was just
getting started in harry potter brent
also starred in another children's
fantasy film thunder pants which is
about a boy who can't stop farting
needless to say it didn't become a
cinematic classic
[Music]
while grind does not take the title role
in thunder pants he does play the best
friend a child scientist who helps the
tutor deal with his worrisome
windbreaking in fairness to grint this
ridiculous romp isn't all that terrible
it's a fairly fun children's flick that
will at least leave you laughing from
the ludicrous lighthearted gags but with
grint attempting a more serious and
dramatic career this can't be a movie
he's proud to trot out for his new fans
to watch
[Music]